[Music]
all right how's the day been fellas
fantastic still reeling from last night
I'm still processing the face are you
yeah listen I didn't stop thinking about
it last night I'm not even joking I'm
not I went home I my family has a group
text I text everybody my luck listen up
you gotta steal some ice tickets I was
not kidding when I said in the panel
today I felt went to sleep in Wakanda I
woke up still in Wakanda mmm-hmm I
needed to be in one that I wouldn't have
been in your tribe no no of course I'd
be with the female like but I really was
like it was it was a really intense deep
sense of just a pride and just feeling
good and saying did you see they're like
come on it was amazing hmm it's a story
of agency yeah agency culture community
family you know so it'sit's a lot of
different things that you could dig into
pretty quickly and and it grounds the
film in a really great way that allows
it to be this action world trotting
adventure and you can believe it you
know what I mean
because they're anchored you can't help
but I couldn't help but think about and
make a correlation and I know this was
shot well before but here we are in a
time where African nations are being
called into question for what they are
and who the people are and then you show
this film with all this beauty and and
like these these people who are so regal
and roil and the resources are so full
in this this country I mean I don't
believe in coincidences the images of
the film that we saw last night is the
truth you know and and and that's been
hidden from people and the narratives in
in in the Western society so it's now
that we that's our responsibility to
kind of show
the different show and power
perspectives that don't usually get a
platform you're right about the
waterfall scene mind blowing you saw it
on that big screen last night in a
chance chance coming up and it's crazy
and then his chart and then him coming
out it's crazy I mean and when you saw
yourself come out in that mask looking
like you and look looking like you're
looking did you not just sit up a little
taller in your seat yeah well you know
seeing it for the first time which we
all were last night seeing it for the
first time is it was really okay it's
staggering because you're acting a lot
of time against these green screens so
you don't actually get to see what's
happening or have a full understand
you're just trusting and you're trusting
that you know we're in a waterfall we
did have the water and some things there
but there's a lot of you know
imaginative work at hand so seeing it
fully done and finished that was like oh
so this is what we were doing we're
being introduced to a condom that we
just instinctually and instinctively
were creating what we hadn't gotten to
see it and so actually being in that
room and seeing it was just it was
something brand-new for us there you
were talking about all of the themes
within this movie and I think I lost
count at about 27 but I was saying
earlier there was one that really stood
out to me where I felt like it really
showed the measure of a man and how
strong a man can be without trying to
exert his physical strength and that was
a scene with you like for me that was
everything what was it like for you to
act in that scene with with deny and
really because a lot of men might think
backing down is not manly but I thought
it showed great strength it's the most
strongest strongest thing you can do to
reassess the decision you've made you
know it's the kind of go and seeing that
you've caused her and someone you love
and going oh I don't know I've gone too
far
I've gone too far and I have to have to
accept the
what the the cause or the eventually the
stuff that's being done cause of my
decisions and I think it was really
important for me that arc ended in that
way because it I thought it was honest
and I think it's needed and that's what
you wanna do you want to put that
message out there
and say there is another option there is
another way to handle things even if
you've made a decision beforehand yeah I
didn't know that well I mean I didn't
know it was coming but when it hit me
like that I was like oh I'm getting
emotional saying this and especially
with a black cop exactly that's king
couple I mean that's happening that's
our responsibilities in in whatever we
do is to kind of show the truth yes our
truth yeah exactly and showing this man
seriously give it to this woman give it
up to this one and I was just I was done
I was completely done in that scene um I
was trying even two minutes before the
film to get something out of all of you
all
nobody was given anything what's the
craziest thing somebody did to try and
get a secret about this film from you I
think for me it's always the kind of
clandestine slip in the question and
like a time of like really great
conversation and like laughs so you know
I've had things like we having a good
time were laughing and an industry
person will be like so that's crazy so
so did you sign on for like multiple
films yeah but this this food though
I mean so as people always try to slip
in little jobs and try to get
information when they think you might
not be paying attention yeah you're not
on yes I think I find it when people
just say flowers oh so who's gonna
bionic arm
[Laughter]
get out press whilst doing it is this
that thing you don't want to know you
don't really know how to spoil everyone
wants to sit down there's so much it
better that no information and you know
it you know you've seen it you've seen
it now so you're no worth you're right
away you're right as well it is worth
the wait yes but I still want to know
inquire my eyes wanna know so did you
sign on yeah but is it a poster in
multiple areas like the films you signed
on for
[Laughter]
who was the like most instinctive or
like the most natural fighter of all of
you on what was the training like how
intense was that Chad Chad does doesn't
marshal said he'd be like just training
but intakes and he just be doing moves
if he's guy and I'm gonna oh wow this
guy ain't playing yeah relationship with
him where I just like I'll sneak up on
him I push them on punch him and I run
and that's kind of the only way it hit
him because he's always kind of ready
and like peripherally he'll see you and
just punch one day one day I'll get you
one day POW right in the kisser i'ma
kiss tell me about this coming to
America themed birthday party
Oh God
this is happy boy who was I was so happy
with Chad was sectioned check yeah no he
looked like he was Randy Watson or
something I don't know what he was in
the singer
he was singing and it was it was like I
didn't know how deep it was I kind of
came in a roof designed all our costumes
like was made denial appear and then I
was a discussion question qu but she put
these sunglasses in no woah-oh denies it
I just changed person
I just came and put yo like things like
this two actors all we need is an
imagination here like a different color
yeah not to mention the whole thing I
was like Mansa Musa I'm gonna go at
samos yeah I'm gonna put on gold
everywhere and just like go in is in
between the shoe we're like some of the
best poison yeah but I feel like it
demonstrates the kind of community that
worried janelda made you know man they
hosted applause and yeah and and said
thank you to celebrate you because she
was like saying we know you've done it
Atlanta that is our space such an
inspiration we was all the enemy we vibe
she paid us new music we just fired and
enjoyed and it was just so wait Martin
Freeman was good down by Freeman was on
the drums getting down getting down
drops in that light like a G Martin
Freeman is a gene
Marin Shelly that's why I fooled him I
love I'm so mad that he walked out of
this room two minutes ago and I did he's
asking us ways possible
so then Ryan was wrong he wasn't
directing two white guys it was wrong
everybody just one just one only what's
wrong you know and that wide open Africa
[Music]
you guys are amazing
[Music]